[Musik]
von allein
jeder politiker in europa weiß haargenau
was hier passiert und trainer trifft
entscheidet natürlich entschuldigt
der zustand der winter laufen wenn ich
hoffe dass die leute dann machte mir
selber fahren überfahren
die stiege das wasser lässt sich auf dem
boot mit dem zeit wirklich auf mich zu
das ist fahrlässigkeit
quali fahrlässigkeit vor einigen tagen
auf lesbos wieder strandete ein schiff
mit flüchtlingen vor der griechischen
insel und wieder schaut europa weg
einige wenige handeln zb michael reber
aus münsingen
wir sind die menschen die helfen statt
wegzuschauen und was können sie in
dieser tragödie ausrichten
davon handelt dieser film
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sie kommen aus syrien und afghanistan
viele haben eine monatelange flucht
hinter sich geprägt von ständiger angst
und ungewissheit
rund 1000 franken pro person haben sie
ihrem schlepper in der türkei für die
zehn kilometer lange überfahrt bezahlt
[Musik]
die eu ist überfordert seien helfer vor
ort freiwillige tragen die ganze
verantwortung
wie kann man direkt befragt bevor ich
glaube ich so haben im sturm im sommer
gummiboot hier übers wasser und sagen
auto möglich ist und das ist das wo der
heimat aber wahnsinnig schwarze griffe
[Musik]
es ist ruhig in syrien müsste hier im
raum verbannt wird
das ist also hier stattfindet das ist
realität und stelle - überdies stellen
über 200 flüchtlinge waren an bord unter
ihnen ein journalist aus syrien
[Musik]
bei feiern
die türkische polizei hat geschossen
rund um unser schiff herum die kinder
hatten große angst
alle haben geweint das war sehr
gefährlich auf dem überladenen boot und
ich kann einfach nicht vergessen dass
die türkische polizei versucht hat uns
zu erschießen
[Musik]
im sommer machte michael reber mit
seiner frau ferien in griechenland
er sah das elend und wusste wer muss
helfen
seit vier monaten ist er nun auf lesbos
er sagt als selbständiger it und
unternehmensberater könne er sich das
erlauben zwischen showbusiness ist es so
aus
wir wissen sie hamburg es geht
es geht weiter es gibt hier fördert
nordküste und einem fernen osten seien
beobachtungsposten und die eigentliche
wiege bitte unbedingt auch eine
abordnung der pole position und platz
dann wissen wir sehr genau dass diese
effektive last der letzten stunde
was aber noch nicht weiß am gleichen tag
sinken vor der türkischen küste drei
flüchtlingsboote 36 menschen ertrinken
[Musik]
eine million flüchtlinge gelangte
letztes jahr über das mittelmeer nach
europa die hälfte von ihnen kam hier auf
der kleinen ferieninsel lesbos an
[Musik]
in jeder dieser schwimmwesten steckte
ein mensch der sich nach einem besseren
leben sehnt einem leben in würde und in
sicherheit
[Musik]
die insel ist überfordert mit dem
ansturm der flüchtlinge
es waren freiwillige helfer die einen
olivenhain pachteten weil das offizielle
camp von moria chronisch überlastet war
in wenigen wochen bauten sie ein
inoffizielles camp mit funktionierender
infrastruktur auf
eine der initiantinnen ist ließ kabinett
die 26 jährige arbeitet im
koordinationsteam des camps der job der
zürcherin ist anspruchsvoll
sie hilft nicht nur flüchtlingen die
sich im camp nicht zurecht finden sie
koordiniert auch helferinnen und helfer
die meist keine erfahrung haben
es ist beeindruckend was laien aus der
ganzen welt auf die beine gestellt haben
und dies ohne staatliche gelder und ohne
zentrale verwaltung sind wo meistens
komplett nass surehand und große meist
uns auch und david nicht weitergehen so
wie wenn man immer weniger schulen
zusammen schwierig aber zu stellen neue
hochs aus wonach die stimmungswechsel
kleider essen zählte das ganze camp
basiert auf privaten spenden
warum hat sie
es entscheidet dass man von 76 sitzung
des metallica was passiert einen
ausblick im bereich um mich persönlich
sehr interessiert und einfach
leichtigkeit humanitären kommando und
die möglichkeit sehr groß für uns in
europa für andere
die flüchtlinge sind auf der durchreise
ihr ziel ist das europäische festland
bevor sie weiterreisen dürfen müssen sie
sich registrieren lassen ein nadelöhr
mit oft tage langer wartezeit
warum haben sie ihre heimat afghanistan
verlassen
[Musik]
das tape ist weil in unserem land keinen
frieden herrscht die taliban der us
arbeitslosigkeit
wir haben so viele probleme darum habe
ich mein land verlassen
wohin wollen sie gehen
nach deutschland oder schweden
vielleicht und wir sind sie nach lesbos
gekommen
über berge durch flüsse und dann per
schiff wie lange einen monat lang ließ
kabinett studierte an der renommierten
london school of economics humanitäre
nothilfe und entwicklungszusammenarbeit
[Musik]
müssen wir die trockenen leute dort
rüber bringen
ja die trockenen leute nein sorry ich
meine die nassen ja immer zuerst
trockene kleider geben und dann das
ticket für die registrierung müssen wir
sie dorthin ring
nun schaut einfach dass sie wissen wohin
sie gehen müssen
die ska band arbeitet wie alle anderen
freiwilligen unentgeltlich vom strand
werden die erschöpften flüchtlinge
direkt ins camp gefahren
der finger
mein mann kam in syrien bei einem
russischen luftangriffen ums leben
es war schrecklich ich musste fliehen
dann saßen wir in izmir fest und
warteten auf die möglichkeit ein boot zu
erwischen
ich hatte große angst dass es zu
gefährlich sein könnte dass meine kinder
ertrinken
aber wir mussten die türkei unbedingt
verlassen
ich betete einfach dass alles gut geht
die überfahrt dauert dann zwei stunden
wo findet die schwierigste moment und
situation für mich ein thema persönliche
geschichte erzählen was sie erlebt hat
oder was passiert ist ein film über die
ganze familie verloren haben
seit philipp wo ja wahrlich schreckliche
sachen urlaub kennt ihr das erzählt
unser trainer ferdi zählen zum teil
und das berührt mich immer so
persönliche schicksal eigentlich am
meisten berührt
[Musik]
beide setzen sich seit monaten für die
flüchtlinge ein
liska berne tier im camp michael reber
bei der ankunft am strand heute treffen
sie sich zum ersten mal der münsinger
hat eine band aus der schweiz
organisiert
[Musik]
musik sorgt für einige unbeschwerte
momente
[Musik]
michael reber sagt es sei wichtig die
flüchtlinge nicht wie ein problem
sondern wie menschen zu behandeln
[Musik]
kannst du dir
die humanitäre katastrophe hinterlässt
spuren
und weil immer weitere flüchtlinge
ankommen hat niemand zeit die strände zu
säubern
für die ferieninsel eine doppelte
tragödie
[Musik]
michael weber bereit das nachtessen für
seine helferinnen und helfer vor
sie leben in ferienapartments die ehe
mit spendengeldern gemietet hat was hat
sich recht dass sie letztes um in athen
entschieden zurück wonach der erde
sondern dass sie damit auf wunsch kann
nicht sein so lange nach
gleichberechtigung gleichberechtigung
zwischen deutscher aus der mit hey ich
möchte keine später auseinander und das
handy gelüftet wie in der humanistischen
gymnasium gang war fürs eigene methode
ist das mannschaftlich sie dass sie
gleich lachte und verdanken die hütte
bezeugt und das stellt hier nicht dahin
größte immerhin scheine tracht oder sie
wenn du gewartet wieder sagen wodurch
zurück und das ist das sagt sie die
linien damit dass wir hier schon
gehandelt linz aus der ohnmacht breit wo
man vorher kamen die ganzen nachricht
ich sehe wenn die fraktion lehne die
verstanden und für mehr als das haben
jetzt gleichzeitig machen
der 39 jährige begeisterte seine ganze
familie für das projekt seine frau und
seine geschwister waren auch schon hier
diese woche unterstützt ihn seine mutter
christine
platzeck wörtlich ich würde dich mal
nicht die geflossenen zum
organisationstalent und simon ist
deshalb das morgendliche telefon gesagt
wenn es darum geht was mir da und soll
zusammen mit daniel new york stopp ist
krebs kopf und da ist sie wohl immer
starke kräftig gesenkt hat es nicht
sturm hat richtig den stetig steigenden
aber selber geschaut hat und weiß alle
angeknüpft hat oder nicht einfach besser
gefühlt
das stimmt kürzer und der studie heißt
wenn ihr hier oder hängen
das hat ein 24 freiwillige stehen
zurzeit für rebers organisation
schweizer kürzt im einsatz
gemütlich wird auch dieser abend nicht
nachts kommen besonders viele boote an
[Musik]
bei dunkelheit und gefährlichen
witterungsbedingungen sind die plätze
auf den boten billiger
[Applaus]
[Musik]
morgens und fünf weht ein eisiger wind
fünf stunden hatte das boot übers meer
durch die nacht
[Musik]
ja
nur wenige lüthen ist diese flexibel
sehr schlau wenn wir immer groß frage
was machen
das müsse jetzt geklärt und hiermit
trockner weiter und so ist diese gefahr
dass dies als unprofessionell ich viel
zu lang
das ist unprofessionell viel
improvisieren und monaten verzweifelter
und wenn sie bezahlt haben ist daher
eine frau liest organisationen hat aber
die sind also machen wir job
[Musik]
die freiwilligen helfer fordern die
sogenannte safe pässe die sichere
überfahrt für flüchtlinge
nur so könne dieser tragödie ein ende
gesetzt werden
[Musik]
safe passierte des widerspruchs mit
zwischenrufen gestört hier das machen
das heißt es wird bedeutet liegt dort
der hardcore und hier ist es ganz normal
adobe ist flügge oder mit der fahrer
gerade hier ist es als würde beurteilt
mir hat es eine waffenmesse inhaftiert
ist selber strom
[Musik]
letztes jahr ertranken 3771 menschen
beim versuch nach europa zu gelangen
3771 sinnlose tote männer frauen kinder
die kirche der hauptstadt setzte ein
zeichen und öffnete den christlichen
friedhof für muslime einige der gräber
tragen bloß eine nummer den toten blieb
nicht einmal die würde eines anständigen
grabes
die leute kommen von weit her um hier
ein besseres leben zu finden und dann
ertrinken sie wir erleben das täglich
das muss aufhören
man muss eine lösung finden damit die
menschen hier nicht so qualvoll sterben
wenn wir griechen auswandern wollen
steigen wir einfach in ein flugzeug
die tragödie nimmt kein ende
[Musik]
seit monaten so und jeder weiß es und es
passiert nichts
aber nicht wirklich ignoriert es wird
nur aus einer perspektive für die eigene
sicherheit diskutiert und nicht aus der
perspektive von deiner mannschaft und
das ist nicht ironisch sie nicht wie sie
war
[Musik]
seit anfang jahr sind schon wieder über
29.000 flüchtlinge angekommen
58 menschen sind ertrunken
[Musik]